hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a CP
containment breach we just finished off
radical Larry will not finish him off
but we locked him up like the maniac he
is and we have a burnt note with a key
card code thingy that'll probably maybe
definitely actually work this time so I
just got a fire but now I've been down
that way down that way again screw that
screw that noise so we can finally start
to make some progress I'm going to
backtrack a bit here see what we can
find in terms of useful stuff I do not
like these rooms with her where where
where one seven three could just zip
around beneath me it's not happy fun
times alright so anyway we are gonna
carry on our way where it's on hopefully
there'll be peace when we are done I
just want to lay my weary head to rest
and stop crying there's gotta be another
way back here that I have yet to go on
down okay that's that's the bugs the
bugs containment breach thing that I saw
in the last episode I think that's where
I came from I'm not mistaken yeah I
think that's that's where we started so
we came out here and we went that way so
let's see what's down this way besides
also office hmm
crap wait was there anything else bust
down that way besides the maybe there
was I have to double check just to be
diligent
where'd you go are you there yeah here
we go here we go here we go where are
you ha ha ha
I hate that guy so much I hate that
[ __ ]
I hate him I hate him he's everywhere
nah this is a dead end isn't it yeah ok
this was a dead end
ahh where are you where are you right
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha I'm getting got
it going yo not killing you you're
pretty good at killing me but I'm
getting good at avoiding you running
away like a scared little baby but I'm
good at oh god I hate that guy
I hate that guy so much so let's do
scary huh
going back a bit so I've already covered
all of these areas this way I need to
get to new area somewhere over here I
don't I don't know what other avenues I
could go down oh I can go in the tunnel
now I can actually go through the tunnel
without worrying about radical lair
being there oh we go zombie baby it oh
that's right doo-doo-doo I like baby
game so anything other than that I don't
think there's anything any in there I
don't think so oh I don't think so I
gotta go this way I gotta close that
door behind me
did I leave now that he's still it's
still there he does not go away anymore
1 7 3 does not go away
it's really really really nerve-racking
know that he could pop around any
quarter and stop my neck in it like a
twig what was down this way death
destruction probably aha I know I found
the tunnel okay so if I go down here now
I'm bound to find the other end
oh and be able to get out of here right
right
all I know is that it's obscenely dark
but hopefully it'll be a little better
without my gas mask don't tell me you're
down there you [ __ ]
oh god Kirk oh did I just get turned
around I don't know oh don't tell me
he's down here I don't want him to be
down here oh baby please I don't like
this plane I like this plane Oh Oh like
a door door door door door door
yeah that's where I came down that's
another bad it's good in this way I know
you guys can't see anything but I can't
okay door isn't locked work oh no I just
caught the head damn it I broke it
[ __ ] no I didn't oh thank
huh hey taro hey elzar in radio okay so
nothing there hold you hold you close it
close it close it close it where's a
damn thing we're closing clonic I hate
him so much I hate him
he's so much worse he's so much worse
now
got any other end of the facility and oh
oh oh I could um shut off the computer
power here and then he'll ask me to go
back but if I shut them off here maybe
it'll do some other things if I don't
listen to him that might help secondary
lighting one and door control off okay
good right good good good good good good
okay we're good right
we're good we did what we came here for
I no one's gonna murder kill us
no one's gonna murder kill us right
right
wrong you are wrong sir don't want to go
that way that's another cast room I
don't want to go this way either no ICP
Oh
evacuation shelter
facility we started school personnel
loud when they escape this
contained oh no they're here they're
gonna kill me I'm just gonna blend the
gas master real quick just because I
like the infinite run that it gives me
it released the stairs wait a minute
hang on didn't they say that they added
something with scp-172 82 is there
something here
ow my eyeball okay ah pitch black this
why can't I see anything why can't I see
why can't I see hope I'm going up this
here mi mi okay kid don't know how but
idea there all right what's over here
aha hmm Maynard nine nine one one those
our 9s those our nines I'm looking at
them they are nines I know you guys last
time said they look like zeros they are
9s they have a little loop on the bottom
there are nine okay so nine nine one one
eleven i'm in dr. maenads office oh now
what what what is in here it's out
proceeding what is dr. Maynard behind
all this hmm
wait a minute was that ah come on don't
tell me that was it don't do not tell me
that was it really
that was it that was it
ah ah that that that was it
you gotta be kidding me dr. Maynard you
son of a [ __ ] you're useless fat check
a crap that's what you are
I don't you are oh come on come on oh
come on I was expecting something
amazing ah boss uh-huh
why is he gotta be a dick why does he
gotta be where are you I must turn to
the left there thank you where am i okay
we're just gonna staring contest real
here I got trapped in here with you so
let dance boogie list dance
are you moving ow my neck was a wobbly
Meghan both of us who's he what's he
doing the was he doing the safety dance
the safety dance
that's a 372 that's that's the creature
that I saw I saw him I saw him I saw
three seven two I saw him in the last
episode I saw him he was there I don't
know why I failed at getting there
huh all personnel are advised to report
any brief flickering movements in the
corner there yeah I saw him nice John
I got him really you dog dope I'm not
crazy
takes a where am i okay good alright
let's just zoom through here fast as
possible you're in the middle room and
so I am outside the room Harry go
these white Oh like above I don't know
where this leading class come on back
because this is just on that end badge
fudgesicle what up super this is the
boot and super here we go
where are you where are you where you ha
ha got my way [ __ ] good
I don't know why go that's our kick
carrying on saving ah damn I gotta go
through here I'm not gonna fight again
do that just it's not that big a deal to
not be able to spread through here I'd
rather you guys be able to see something
the scary darkness that I know you all
don't like droll big movies big whiny
babies as opposed to me who is
exceptionally brave and whatnot and
whatnot
ok so I went down here there was another
path that I could go
I guess either one of these wait which
way did I come from I think hey hang on
close this way ah yeah either one of
these I'm gonna go through this way
though because I think that other one
kind of loses back oh yeah buddy
where are you are carry on oh come on my
time oh come on there we go
bro pro-level al/499 oh no no not the
butt ghost no no not my boy donate my
pot okay so is there anything else in
the restroom that I need to know about
what ahh oh my god what up just scare
anyone did that scare anyone
what oh I I I've dropped my whoa hang on
sorry about that everybody
ha ha everybody all right okay yeah what
happened was I I crossed my legs
underneath my table and I moved my foot
and I yanked the cable the USB cable for
my camera okay we're good we're good
we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
all good sorry if I scared anyone with
that okay so carrying on ah
good thing I blinked right then in there
holy balls
oh god oh god oh god okay okay okay okay
so I got to be careful because I know
that the task force has got to be coming
soon I don't know where but hopefully I
can lead them through one of these
things
I mean that'll be helpful I mean they're
all pretty - what is this this is new
this is new I hear oh no this is not new
this is not new this is the same what
are these things okay eventually I'm
gonna have to go down there I know this
I know I eventually I'm gonna have to go
down there so let's make it right now
okay
hey buddy
oh hi hon Peter I can't move I can't
move down we don't open don't blink I'm
gonna back
but if I blink over here he's I'm safe
okay link over here I'm pretty safe not
gonna kill me where are you where are
you friend oh where are you my friend
Lee where are you where are you where
are you ah don't you go get me what is
down here what is down here what is down
here Oh God I see what's down there the
only way out is down there I have to go
through there but not right now I don't
I could save that for another day can
screw that Oh God
I was almost out too if I'd have turned
around instead of what was that about
screaming I saw something okay so thank
you all so much for watching hope you're
enjoying this I certainly am all joining
all the new stuff so click the
annotation for videos that I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
oh wow you all know filming me
okay handle gonna be partner another one
is tainted